c'est Dani qui chantait sans astérixte
ça va Dani très bien merci oui oui tu es
super tu as coupé tes cheveux Dison oui
oui tout r ils sont ah es vraiment les
cheveux complètement à rat enfin il y en
a à peine 2 cm m non on prend vraiment
pour une fille parce que tous les
garçons ont les cheveux longs alors ah
bon c'est pour ça que tu t'es fait ou ou
oui parce que tu portes aussi tout le
temps des pantalons j'ai remarqué oh pas
tout le temps quand même faut pas
exagérer ah c'est quand même une de un
de tes vêtements favoris bon tu lis
Astérix toi ah oui beaucoup mais c'est
pas astérique ça c'est c'est astérisque
ou ou je sais quelle différence y a-t-il
entre astérisque et Astérix aucune
comment aucune aucune je crois parce que
ça ve rien dire ni quoi non un
astérisque c'est un petit signe qu'on
met sur astérique as je sais plus où
j'en suis d'ailleurs asis regarde astérx
le Gaulois et ben tu sais aussi bien que
moi ce que c'est oh bah tiens et les
autres TR titres c'est je prends le N et
non non non il y en a une qui s'appelle
la fille à la moto et puis l'autre elle
s'appelle la coupée pleine ah bah